let's look at a very interesting segment
from fox news yesterday
this is a segment in which um jesse
waters
i believe is the host of this program
uh this right winger who's very popular
on social media one of the top view
getters on facebook
dan bongino
is a guest or panelist
and the topic is crime in the united
states this is a favorite topic right
now of the right to lie about and to
deceive people about uh on right wing
media and fox um i guess she's like a
contributor she's a guest on this
program fox contributor jessica tarlov
absolutely crushes
waters and bongino
um now i don't i jessica tarlov may be a
centrist i don't know that much about
her i'm not calling her a hero i'm not
saying anything other than
in this particular segment she's really
really good at crushing the dishonest
delusional lies
of two of these guys on fox news so
let's look at the segment again the
framing here is the crime surge
which republicans are attributing to joe
biden
but they're using 2020 data
to attribute it to joe biden now you
might be saying hold on david
trump was president in 2020 how does
that have to do with joe biden and that
is exactly the right question so let's
take a look at the segment
and the spike in murders again was only
in areas dominated by liberal
politicians so this is obviously not
true it's obviously has something to do
with the politics not kovan so the
framing there is we're going to talk
about the fact that the crime is up in
cities
rather than the fact that the crime was
up while trump was president but of
course we've talked before
uh cities tend to be run by democrats
quote dangerous cities are run by
democrats and safe cities are run by
democrats because in general democrats
prefer cities and republicans prefer
non-cities okay let's see how jessica
tarlov deals with this i'm not sure that
it has something to do necessarily with
the politics there are a few things that
are important here one jesse we'll do
another segment on that but all those
countries you read they don't have a
rampant gun problem like the united
states of america does check how many
weapons people can still kill you with a
knife go down but they're not they're
they're not enough to colombia
where people got knifed all the time and
it's still nothing close to our murder
rate so okay
this is a this is they love this talking
point but it's very dumb
knives create less death than guns in
equivalent situations part of it is to
kill someone with a knife
there's something much more
sometimes viscerally repelling i mean
the action right of stabbing someone to
death you've got to be people aren't
throwing knives from across the room
you've got to be right on someone and
the fact that with a gun you can create
more distance and still inflict damage
to someone
just makes it less likely that a mass
stabbing would even be attempted in the
same way that the mass shooting would be
but we have data about mass stabbings
and most people survive one of the most
deadly mass stabbings we covered it at
the time it was in 2019 in japan
two people were tragically killed two
kids
17 were injured and survived someone
with a semi-automatic weapon in that
situation with the amount of time that
this incident lasted would almost
certainly kill many many more people so
good that good for jessica tarlov for
pointing that out jesse waters is going
to say people can be killed by knives
fine it may not convince that many
people on fox news but justin guitar
love is getting it right now let's get
to the 2020 thing which is just
unbelievably dumb that they're doing the
data that we're talking about is 2020
those were the trump years so all of
this blaming on president biden that's
happening now actually under president
biden's watch the murder rate has even
gone down another important component of
the fbi data that the short-term
increases was in all regions not just in
those liberal cities all regions that
means in places where conservatives are
that means that this can all be because
of bail reform to fund the police yada
yada yada and also the murder rate and
the crime rate overall is lower than it
was in the 1990s so conservatives are
running around screaming we've never
seen anything like this you have seen
something like that so these are all
very good points and they all should be
dealt with individually
if the problem is that the the danger
and crime
are happening in liberal cities we need
to adjust for the fact that liberals
tend to live in cities and run cities
and conservatives tend to overall live
in more rural and suburban areas and
in terms of per capita crime rates
we actually see that per capita some of
those rural areas are really really
dangerous the problem is it's hard to
compare a city
to a tiny town you have you have really
have to look at an area where you have
enough of a population to actually
evaluate this
uh and then of course number two
long term the crime rate has been going
down we did see a bump in 2020 but trump
was president and much of it was despair
related to the mishandled pandemic they
were blaming biden back then saying well
it's the culture of people who would
vote for biden combined with people
saying we should defund the police even
though it hadn't actually been done it
had just been proposed by some
but i thought the buck stopped with
trump or whoever was president so this
is a really great example of
the narratives that they push
not having anything to do with the facts
and a sensible person in this case
jessica tarlov just saying hold on let's
put some facts in the way of the
propaganda how many fox viewers were
convinced by this i have no idea maybe
not many but this is exactly the way
that if you're going to participate and
jessica tarlov is a contributor to fox
so clearly she is if you're going to
participate in these setup
uh
debates that are set up against you
this is exactly the way to do it we'll
have more on this on the david pakman
show instagram which you can find at
david pakman show you can also find me
on instagram david.pakman
one of our sponsors is atlas vpn stop
letting big corporations invade your
privacy atlas vpn makes your ip address
anonymous and encrypts your internet
traffic which keeps your info private
from big tech companies from your
internet service provider even from
governments atlas vpn also keeps you
safe from hackers trying to steal your
data and financial info and lets you
access your favorite streaming services
as if you were in another country so you
can watch shows and movies you wouldn't
otherwise be able to i use atlas vpn on
all of my devices phone computer tablet
anytime i'm connected to the internet
couldn't be is easier to use you turn it
on it stays on you keep your information
private and right now my audience can
get atlas vpn for just a dollar 39 a
month with a 30 day money back guarantee
you just have to go to atlas v dot pn
slash pacman the link is right
underneath this video